Here we are,
everybody loves a good movie and the
genre has a lot of competition.
You've got John Hughes classics like the
Breakfast Club and Ferris Bueller's day
off nineties,
teen romcoms like 10 things I hate about
you and she's all that Richard Linklater
is coming of age,
comedy,
dazed and confused or recent hits like
the fault in our stars and love Simon.
You could even throw all eight Harry
Potter movies into the mix.
Why not?
But when I search [inaudible] dot com,
which everybody knows is the authority
on ranking stuff.
I'm disappointed to find that my
favorite teen movie doesn't even crack
the top 100.
Of course I'm talking about Kenji Ecosoc
whose turn of the millennium
masterpiece.
That.
Okay.
Boy,
premise of battle royale is really
simple.
In a dystopian Japan,
a classroom of teenagers is chosen every
year and shipped to an island where they
have to fight to the death until only
one is left standing.
You might recognize this premise from
the hunger games books,
the first of which came out eight years
after battle royale and nine years after
the book by cashew into Cami on which
it's based.
This concept is also the basis for the
hugely popular video game,
fortnight battle royale and its
predecessor player unknown's
battlegrounds,
which was at least in part,
inspired by Fuka sock who's moving.
Unlike the hunger games,
battle royale is remarkably contained.
There is no larger world,
no political intrigue,
plotline.
The audience is just dumped into this
horrific situation with the characters
and we experience it shocks as they do
and they are shocked.
It's definitely a violent movie,
but it's the execution of violence that
makes battle royale so great.
And this should come as no surprise
though.
I didn't know this when I first saw the
movie at Summer Camp Age Sixteen.
Battle Royale is the final film of
Japanese alter Kinji Fuka soccer.
He made this incredibly vigorous film
about teenagers at age 70,
which is amazing,
but by then focus.
Aco was a master,
a criminally underappreciated master of
Japanese in world cinema.
He made his mark on the industry in the
19 seventies with a breathtaking series
of films about Japanese gangsters,
the Yakuza in the chaos after World War
II.
Unlike the more traditional Yakuza
films,
Fuka Socceroos movies have a wild manic
energy to them.
The camera work is designed to throw you
into the action.
It's a thrilling,
disorienting experience to watch them
and whose message in those films comes
through loud and clear in a society by
war,
friendship,
comradery.
Even the famous codes of honor of the
Coosa only stretch so far.
It was truly every man for himself,
and if someone could get an advantage by
betraying his friend,
he was more likely to do it than not.
It took a sack whose films?
The honorable ones are often the first
to be killed.
Yeah,
he killed him.
Him have to be in a custody can you
highlight one night every night
in battle royale,
the same philosophy holds in the chaos
of the game.
The speed at which friends turn into
enemies can give you whiplash and the
violence,
the violence of the films is sudden
devastate.
As a viewer,
it's like you're one of the students.
It all comes so fast at the beginning
that you just want to pause and get a
grip on things,
but there's no time for them.
The ones who trust too liberally are the
ones who get killed.
First,
it may seem like battle royale is a
fable of nihilism with mindless,
brutal killing,
doled out to anyone and everyone,
but the violence in [inaudible] whose
vision has a purpose,
like all great team movies,
Battle Royale is really about
friendships that may be a little hard to
see,
but focus on who's interested in what
friendship really means when the gloves
are off in the most barbaric
circumstances.
What does human connection mean in the
context of humanity's capacity for
unspeakable violence?
At that time,
unspeakable violence was very much alive
in the memory of the older generation in
Japan.
It tested them in ways that the younger
generation couldn't begin to understand.
This is what life was like for fruit
soco himself when he was 15,
the same age as the students in the
film,
so you know,
she,
she was really not that much data on my
level.
You Eel know.
I'm like,
you want to look that up?
So do you want your pillows
in the movie?
It's almost as if the older generation
represented by a teacher devices the
game as a way to communicate their
experiences with the youth and it's
almost as if he made the film for the
same reason.
Battle Royale is interested in the kind
of friendship that can't be explored at
high school.
It's friendship tainted by a deeply
cruel world,
but it's all the more poignant when it
persists in spite of that fact.
Well,
Michael saw sick idea.
It's about the last movie is a lot of
things.
It's Blackley comical.
It's scary.
It's a naked look at humanity and it's a
gripping piece of balls to the wall.
Entertainment directed by a man with a
lifetime of skill and experience.
It's a teen movie and it deserves to be
considered with the very best of that
genre.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by skill
share,
which is an online learning community
for creators with more than 21,000
classes and everything from graphic
design and film editing to finance an it
security.
You know what?
I learned photoshop,
I learned it through a weird mishmash of
disconnected youtube videos and I think
the process would have gone a lot faster
and better if there was a class
dedicated to teaching me everything that
program could do in a more systematic
way.
That's what skillshare offers.
Learning new skills is really valuable
to me because whenever I learned a new
skill,
it's like a bunch of new ideas are
unlocked in my head.
I think what can I do with this,
and that always,
always helps me with writer's block.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the link in the description,
get their first two months for free.
In those two months,
you could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business.
More importantly,
the skills you learn will help give you
ideas for what that business or art
project could be.
Definitely try it out.
Thanks guys.
We'll see you next time.